we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we have a
voicemail from the Eggman on the topic
of the minimum wage take a listen to
this I gave I really hate corporate
welfare I hate that Walmart Walmart
employees get subsidized by the
government they don't pay enough you're
right about all of that subject
I think big related way to love I want
to ask you how do you address the
Conservatives to tell you they've been
working in a factory for 15 years and
they started at nine bucks an hour they
work their way up to $15 an hour they
make it thirty grand a year and then all
of a sudden the kids at Burger change is
making fifteen thousand thirty grand a
year what does that do to you I know
they all to get paid more you hear the
factories but what is that just the guy
that make fifteen bucks an hour after
fifteen years to earn that position
there and he finds out you can go to
Burger King and they can pay amount of
money a Burger King is in a small town
and the factory that paid $15,000 is a
40-minute commute into the city but this
huge revelation some not saying that
it's wrong to raise the money I'm just
asking you what do you say is a guy who
makes that now after 15 years now he
doesn't have to travel yet what's the
cocktail at point-o well the exams on
fire I get the point right which is you
started at nine bucks an hour and a
factory you worked your way up to
fifteen minimum wage gets raised to
fifteen and now you're like wait a
second I've been working twenty years
and I make the same amount of someone
who just starts at age seventeen we're
doing a Burger King its III don't mean
to be sort of like I don't care about
that issue it's just not the primary
issue the fact that there might be waged
jealousy there's an upside though right
if you're a worker at a factory and you
work your way up to fifteen bucks an
hour if the minimum wage goes up to
fifteen bucks an hour all of a sudden
there's way more people who can afford
the widget or whatever it is that that
factory produces and your wage should go
up above and beyond the $15 an hour now
will that actually happen impossible to
predict but I I understand what the
Eggman is saying but it's not something
that we would make Paulo
based off of the idea that some people
might become jealous or upset that
others salaries have have increased I
don't know how you turn that into policy
right and you should maybe be
appreciative of the fact that other
people don't have to go through the
stream the same struggles that you had
to go through or so so you're sort of
glad that hey now people won't have to
do what I did for the last 20 paved the
way I just I just don't think that what
the problem the eggman presents is
something that we should be focusing
heavily on when we think about like what
should people get paid and what is a
living wage on the bonus show today Cobb
feffy is banned as a vanity license
plate in Georgia why we will talk about
that more problems for United Airlines
as an infant overheats while a plane sat
on the tarmac for two hours and an
elderly passenger threw some coins into
a plane's engine for good luck that's
what her religion dictated and it ended
up requiring the full disassembly of a
commercial aircraft engine as well as a
five plus hour delay all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
david pakman.com slash membership is how
you sign up and get instant access to
the bonus show and of course you can
make a pledge of as little as $1 a month
through patreon all pledges welcomed and
appreciated patreon.com slash david
pakman show I will speak to you on the
bonus show